Les Évangiles nous relatent
la passion du Christ Jésus,
le Fils de Dieu.
Après son chemin de croix
était crucifié
par la violence des hommes,
il est mort et a été mis au tombeau.
Le troisième jour,
il est ressuscité des morts.
Tous ces événements
se sont déroulés à Jérusalem.
Aujourd'hui, les pèlerins
viennent du monde entier
pour prier sur ces lieux saints
qui sont englobés
dans la basilique du Saint-Sépulcre,
au cœur de la vieille ville.
Depuis les premiers temps
du christianisme,
ces pierres sont vénérées
comme des reliques ou des icônes.
Comment est-ce que
dans les premiers temps du christianisme,
on a reconnu ces lieux
comme étant ceux de la mort
et de la résurrection du Christ ?
Certainement en fait,
par la tradition locale,
par la tradition orale,
puisqu'il n'y avait
bien évidemment aucun indicateur,
à part qu'il fallait que ce soit
un cimetière dans un jardin.
Ça, ce sont les paroles des Évangiles.
Maintenant, on a aucune trace
du culte judéo chrétien
dans ce cimetière.
Ce qui nous a laissé
affirmer que c'était là,
ça a été la volonté farouche
de l'empereur Adrien, en 135,
d'éliminer cet endroit
de la même manière
qu'il avait éliminé
sur l'esplanade le temple juif.
Adrien veut éliminer
les Juifs de Jérusalem
parce que les Juifs à Jérusalem
refusent de se plier aux lois
et à la religion de l'Empire romain.
Pour lui, la présence judéo chrétienne
est une présence juive.
C'est une secte juive.
Au lieu de la carrière
où Jésus a été crucifié et enterré,
et pour les chrétiens, ressuscité,
il va construire dessus son temple.
Comment peut-on être sûr
que nous avons véritablement
le lieu de la crucifixion
et le lieu
de l'ensevelissement de Jésus ?
D'un point de vue scientifique,
à ce jour, il n'y a aucune assurance.
Point.
En revanche, ce que l'on sait,
c'est que vers 322, 323,
l'empereur Constantin
va demander
à l'évêque de Jérusalem, Macaire,
de retrouver le lieu
de la crucifixion
et de la résurrection de Jésus.
Le texte d'Eusèbe de Césarée,
nous dit Macaire sait où chercher.
Sous le temple d'Adrien,
il va démonter littéralement
le temple d'Adrien
pour aller creuser en dessous,
à l'aplomb de la statue de Jupiter.
Suivant les écrits d'Eusèbe,
Quand il a construit son temple,
Adrien a fait deux choses,
il a mis une statue de Jupiter
à l'aplomb du tombeau de Jésus.
Vous croyez en la toute puissance
de la Résurrection.
La toute puissance
dans mon panthéon à moi, c'est Jupiter.
Au-dessus du calvaire,
il a mis une statue de Vénus.
Vous croyez en la toute puissance
de l'amour,
dans mon panthéon à moi,
l'amour, c'est Vénus.
Il a, en voulant
effacer le culte judéo chrétien,
il l'a affirmé dans le culte romain,
mais en définitive, il l'a marqué.
Bienheureuse faute,
en définitive d'Adrien
qui nous a valu de retrouver
super facilement le lieu de la crucifixion
et de la résurrection de Jésus.
La ville de Jérusalem
est littéralement construite sur le roc,
si bien qu'on ne peut pas creuser
pour mettre un corps en terre.
On va devoir creuser dans la pierre
pour faire des chambres funéraires.
Macaire va trouver des entrées
de chambres funéraires au pluriel.
Parmi ces chambres funéraires,
il va falloir identifier
quelle est celle qui est de Jésus.
Là, on est un petit peu stupéfait
parce que Eusèbe,
qui rapporte
les témoignages oculaires,
ne nous donne aucune indication.
Il semble qu'à l'époque
ce soit tellement assuré que c'est là.
Une fois le lieu exact découvert,
les chrétiens de l'époque
construisent une première église.
La première basilique
de la résurrection est de toute beauté.
La tombe de Jésus
est creusée à flanc de colline.
Eh bien, on va faire sauter la colline
autour de ce rocher initial
pour conserver,
au milieu d'un espace vide,
uniquement le rocher
qui a la chambre funéraire de Jésus.
Au-dessus de ce rocher,
on va donc construire
une magnifique rotonde
avec un déambulatoire
derrière des colonnes.
C'est splendide,
c'est ouvert à 360 degrés de fenêtres.
C'est très lumineux,
c'est décoré de marbres et de mosaïques.
C'est de toute beauté.
C'est le lieu saint.
À côté de ce lieu saint,
il y a un parvis à ciel ouvert,
une forme de cloître.
Dans l'angle
Sud-Est de ce parvis,
il y a le rocher du Calvaire.
Puis, après ce parvis,
ce cloître à ciel ouvert,
il y a véritablement
le martyrion à cinq nefs qui ouvre, lui,
sur le cardo,
l'actuel souk de la ville.
L'édifice se déploie sur 130 mètres.
Sa décoration est magnifique,
surtout de mosaïques,
de figures, de saints,
de boiseries extraordinaires.
Tout ça va être incendié
en 614 par les Perses
et ne va rester,
après la période perse grosso modo,
que la rotonde
et ce cloître à ciel ouvert.
Le sultan de Jérusalem, Hakim,
qui est connu dans l'histoire chrétienne
pour être Hakim le fou,
a décidé de raser
ce qu'il reste du Saint-Sépulcre.
C'est cet évènement
qui va pousser les croisés à venir,
à se mobiliser.
Ça peut mettre un certain temps,
90 ans pour arriver finalement.
En 1099, les croisés arrivent pour sauver.
Ils ne savent pas
ce qu'ils vont sauver presque
puisque Hakim a effectivement détruit.
Mais ils veulent au moins conserver
à la chrétienté le point GPS.
La basilique que nous visitons
aujourd'hui est la basilique romane.
Des croisées construites
à leur arrivée en 1099.
Une chose exceptionnelle à noter.
Les croisées n'ont pas fait table
rase du passé d'avant eux.
Ils ont intégré des éléments
de la basilique initiale
et de sa restauration
par Constantin Monomaque
dans leurs propres édifices.
Ils l'ont construit, eux,
comme croisés qu'ils venaient d'Occident,
mais en faisant aussi intervenir
des ouvriers orientaux
qui ont concouru
à la décoration de la basilique.
Il y a donc des chapiteaux
ou des parties de la façade
qui sont décorés
pour partie par des orientaux.
C'est cette basilique
dans laquelle nous entrons toujours,
dans laquelle vivent littéralement
des communautés religieuses
tout au long de la journée.
À l'entrée de la basilique,
le premier lieu qui est vénéré,
c'est la pierre de l'onction.
Supposément la pierre
sur laquelle on a reposé le corps de Jésus
en le descendant du Calvaire
qui est tout proche
pour préparer le corps de Jésus
avant de le mettre dans sa tombe.
C'est un lieu de vénération,
par conséquent un lieu saint.
Ça fait à peu près 17 siècles qu'on vénère
la préparation du corps de Jésus
à cet endroit-là.
Ce n'est pas le lieu
où ça s'est passé.
Ce n'est même pas la pierre
sur laquelle ça s'est passé,
mais c'est un lieu
où on fait mémoire de ce moment.
Pierre de l'onction.
À droite de la pierre de l'onction,
il faut monter quelques
dizaines de marches
pour accéder
au lieu de la crucifixion,
le calvaire qu'on appelle
aussi le Golgotha.
Il faut monter au calvaire
dont on peut voir le rocher
depuis une dizaine
une quinzaine d'années.
Les Grecs orthodoxes ont enlevé
le marbre qui couvrait le rocher
pour le faire apparaître
avec des dalles de verre,
puis il y a un éclairage.
On peut aussi toucher leur sommet
du rocher du Calvaire.
L'autre lieu saint, bien évidemment,
c'est le tombeau de Jésus.
On entre dans une première pièce
dite La Chapelle de l'Ange.
Au centre de cette pièce,
il y a comme un petit autel.
On aperçoit quelque chose au centre.
Ce quelque chose serait
ce qu'il reste de la pierre
qui a servi à fermer
le tombeau de Jésus.
Puis il y a une seconde pièce
dans laquelle on accède
en se baissant beaucoup parce que
la porte doit faire un mètre de hauteur.
Il y a la reconstitution
d'un banc funéraire
où on vénère le fait
qu'on ait déposé le corps de Jésus
dans une pièce super étroite,
il y a la place pour quatre personnes.
Généralement, les pèlerins
qui entrent se mettent à genoux
ont du mal à regarder autour d'eux
parce qu'il y a les icônes des uns,
les tableaux en argent des autres.
Toutes les églises de Jérusalem
ont des cierges à l'intérieur,
des candélabres,
tout ce que vous voulez.
Surtout, on vous laisse relativement
peu de temps à la vénération
parce que le tourisme de masse
fait que vous êtes le temps
d'une courte prière
dans l'édifice avant de devoir sortir.
Effectivement, l'édicule actuel,
le tombeau de Jésus,
le sommet du christianisme,
le lieu de la résurrection
est un tout petit
peu troublant pour le regard.
Coptes Orthodoxes.
Six églises se partagent
l'espace de la basilique.
Trois d'entre elles ont un rôle majeur
qui sont dans l'ordre protocolaire
les grecs orthodoxes, les franciscains,
représentants de l'église catholique
romaine et les arméniens apostoliques.
Entre les Églises,
il y a une répartition et de l'espace
et de la journée de 24 heures
qui permet à toutes les églises
d'avoir un temps de prière à l'édicule
ou autour de l'édicule
qui lui est réservé tout au long
de l'année, tous les jours.
C'est quand même le lieu,
avec la Nativité à Bethléem,
au monde où tous les chrétiens
entrent au même endroit légitimement,
puisque l'Église,
en définitive, appartient à tous
pour prier les mêmes mystères
et en plus des mystères
sur lesquels ils sont d'accord.
Nativité, incontestablement,
mort, résurrection incontestables.
C'est quand même pas mal
comme lieu d'unité.
Syriaques Orthodoxes
La basilique est en copropriété
entre les différentes églises.
Un règlement détaillé
organise la vie liturgique.
Pour l'entretien de ce lieu saint,
les travaux doivent être acceptés
et organisés par les trois Églises
dites majeures les Arméniens,
les Grecs orthodoxes et les franciscains.
L'édicule avait été fortement endommagé
en 1927 par un tremblement de terre.
Immédiatement après
le tremblement de terre,
les Britanniques ont fait des sondages
sur l'ensemble de la basilique
et sur l'édicule
et ont dit aux églises,
il faut réparer
et la basilique et l'édicule
parce que ça menace ruine.
Les églises, à l'époque,
n'ont pas été capables
de trouver un accord pour convenir
de réparations de l'édicule.
Les Britanniques
ont donc cerclé les véhicules d'acier
en disant au moins ça
va tenir encore quelques années.
Structurellement,
la construction n'est pas solide.
Les Eglises ont pu enfin trouver un accord
et les travaux de restauration
ont pu commencer au printemps 2016.
L'accord a été trouvé
avec les termes suivants
Nous allons faire
une restauration réhabilitation.
Point.
Une restauration conservative,
c'est-à-dire qu'on va faire
exactement le même édicule.
Il n'y a aucune volonté archéologique
dans l'accord.
En revanche,
la technicité de l'opération,
qui consiste à rendre solide
quelque chose qui est
debout mais fragile,
nécessite d'analyser.
Quelles sont les raisons architecturales
pour lesquelles ça se casse la figure ?
C'est ainsi que,
pour la première fois dans l'histoire,
on a pu vérifier
avec des instruments techniques,
ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur
des murs que nous voyons.
On a pu découvrir avec des radars
de pénétration du sol,
des caméras thermiques
avec même des endoscopies,
on a pu découvrir,
qu'à l'intérieur des maçonneries
que l'on voit, il y a le vrai rocher.
C'est le rocher
de la chambre funéraire de Jésus.
Quand le 26 octobre au soir,
on va ouvrir la plaque de marbre
que les pèlerins sont habitués à voir,
on croyait trouver
un endroit vide, on la déplace,
là, on trouve la banquette funéraire,
une banquette funéraire,
la banquette funéraire.
Si c'est effectivement
le tombeau de Jésus,
c'est la banquette funéraire
sur lequel son corps a reposé
L'ouverture du tombeau
qui est survenue en 2016
est la troisième ouverture depuis 1555.
Sur les deux fois précédentes,
on a des descriptions assez sommaires
et on a jamais un dessin
parce que les religieux
qui vont voir ce rocher
sont tellement, je dirais,
scotchés en le voyant,
sont tellement bouleversés
de le voir qu'ils en oublient
leurs esprits.
Figurez-vous qu'il s'est passé
exactement la même chose en 2016.
C'est que nombre de personnes
qui sont entrées dans le tombeau
si vous leur demandez
qu'est-ce que tu as vu ?
Ils ont toutes les peines
du monde à le dire.
Parce qu'en définitive,
ils ont vécu une expérience spirituelle
alors qu'on leur demande
de rendre des comptes
d'une façon très froide,
technique, etcétéra.
Personnellement, pour être entrée
et pour avoir été bouleversée,
j'ai mis un certain temps à réussir
à mettre des mots sur ce que j'ai vu.
Néanmoins j'ai pu prendre des photos,
d'autres ont pris des photos.
Un religieux franciscain,
archéologue a fait un croquis.
Ça a été filmé.
Pour la première fois
en 500 ans, et en définitive,
pour la première fois
depuis la mort de Jésus,
on va savoir renseigné
ce à quoi ressemble sa tombe
ou ce qu'il en reste.
Ce n'est quand même pas mal.
La professeur Moreau Pullo
qui conduit les travaux
et que j'ai interviewé
sur le sujet, m'a dit :
trois de nos instruments
ont arrêté de fonctionner
à l'ouverture du tombeau
et deux de nos ordinateurs
ont eu une phase de crise.
Elle le dit Je suis obligée de le dire
parce que je suis une scientifique
et qu'une scientifique
se doit d'énoncer des faits.
Je lui dis mais quand même,
cette concomitance
où trois instruments
tombent en panne en même temps,
ça ne vous interpelle pas ?
Elle dit : " Nous n'avons
aucune spéculation à faire.
Juste trois instruments,
ce sont cassés
à l'ouverture du tombeau. "
Elle ne veut rien entendre d'autre.
Que disent les religieux là-dessus ?
Parce que les religieux pourraient
peut-être parler, non ?
Dieu sait si
les religieux de Jérusalem,
habituellement, sont capables
de dire beaucoup de choses très vite.
Là aussi, tout le monde se tait,
il n'y a personne.
Aucun religieux
n'a voulu parler de miracle.
Au moment de l'ouverture,
il y avait plus de Grecs,
de franciscains ou d'Arméniens,
il y avait juste des religieux
qui allaient voir de leurs yeux
le point GPS de la résurrection
et ça scotche.
Ça efface énormément de choses
parce que là,
on est véritablement uni.
Il n'y a plus aucune
de nos discordes qui tiennent.
Pendant les heures qui ont suivies
les 60 heures qui ont suivies,
il y a eu une ambiance
entre les religieux assez exceptionnelle
puisqu'il y a eu un roulement
entre les églises pour garder le tombeau,
pas simplement le garder des dégradations,
mais pour entretenir la prière.
Le Saint-Sépulcre est capable
de ces moments de grâce
entre les différentes
confessions chrétiennes,
mais je crois que là,
ça en a été particulièrement fort.
Qu'est-ce qu'on retient ?
Parce que finalement,
ce tombeau, il est vide.
On retient effectivement,
à la faveur de cette ouverture,
qu'il est vraiment ressuscité,
on a rien trouvé.
C'est vraiment vide, on vous le confirme.
Voir ce rocher, c'est entrer
dans une immédiateté de l'histoire.
Il n'y a plus
de distance entre le rocher
où le corps de Jésus a reposé
et ceux qui l'ont vu.
C'est véritablement
la parole dans Matthieu,
"Venez et voyez l'endroit
où on avait déposé son corps."
C'est le lieu de l'absence réelle.
Il est vraiment pas là
parce qu'il est ressuscité.